E
DIFFERENCE. US SECRETARY OF
STATE ANTONY BLINKEN IS CALLING
FOR THE IMMEDIATE RELEASE OF
DETAINED AMERICANS IN RUSSIA IN
A PHONE CALL TODAY WITH HIS
RUSSIAN COUNTERPART, BLINKEN
CALLED THE DETENTION OF
JOURNALISTS EVAN GERSH CEVICHE
ON ACCEPT UNACCEPTABLE AND TO
IMMEDIATELY RELEASE WRONGFULLY
DETAINED AMERICAN CITIZEN PAUL
WHELAN, FORMER U. S AMBASSADOR
TO THE UNITED NATIONS AND FORMER
NEW MEXICO GOVERNOR BILL
RICHARDSON JOINS US NOW.
GOVERNOR GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US. WE ALL KNOW YOU PLAYED A KEY
ROLE IN THE RELEASE OF
BASKETBALL PLAYER BRITTNEY
GRINER FROM A RUSSIAN PRISON
THREE MONTHS AGO. THAT WAS THAT
WAS A WELCOME RELIEF TO A LOT OF
AMERICANS. ARE YOU INVOLVED IN
THE ANY NEGOTIATIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING POTENTIALLY RIGHT NOW
TO GET THESE AMERICANS RELEASED.
WELL JIM, I JUST GOT BACK FROM A
SUCCESSFUL MISSION TO MEXICO
THIS WEEKEND WHERE WE FREED AN
AMERICAN NAVY VETERAN JAMES
FRIZZ WALLED FROM A MEXICAN
PRISON. HE'D BEEN THERE 13 YEARS
WRONGFULLY CHARGED, UH, DECLARED
INNOCENT, SO I HAVEN'T BEEN
TOTALLY UP TO SPEED. I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT. FIRST OF ALL. IF
I AM TO GET INVOLVED TO HELP THE
FAMILY OF EVAN OF THE
JOURNALISTS HAS TO REQUEST THAT
WE DON'T CHARGE THEM ANYTHING.
WE DON'T WORK FOR THE GOVERNMENT
. BUT WE HAVE OUR WAYS AS WE AS
YOU MENTIONED WITH GRINER AND
TREVOR READ THAT HAD SOME
SUCCESS WITH THE RUSSIANS. I
THINK THE SECRETARY OF STATE DID
THE RIGHT THING. CALLING FOREIGN
MINISTER LAVROV WHO'S A
PRACTICAL GUY, UH, AT THAT LEVEL
, I THINK THE NEGOTIATIONS
SHOULD HAPPEN. THERE'S CHANNELS
THAT ARE LOWER LEVEL THAT MAYBE
IF NOT WORKED, SO WELL, BUT THIS
ONE I THINK THIS CALL WAS GOOD.
THEY SHOULD KEEP TALKING TO EACH
OTHER. AND I BELIEVE THERE WILL
BE PROGRESS. BUT I'M READY TO
HELP. I'M READY TO GET INVOLVED
. I DON'T NEED THE OKAY FROM THE
U. S GOVERNMENT, BUT I DO NEED A
REQUEST FROM THE FAMILY AND THEN
THAT'S UP TO THEM. BUT I'M READY
TO HELP. AND GOVERNOR. I HAVE TO
ASK YOU YOUR THOUGHTS ON A US
JOURNALISTS BEING DETAINED.
APPARENTLY THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THIS HAS HAPPENED SINCE THE
COLD WAR. THAT YOU'VE SEEN THE
US JOURNALISTS DETAINED FOR
ESPIONAGE IN RUSSIA. WHAT DO YOU
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT? WELL I
THINK THERE ARE THREE REASONS
WHY THE RUSSIANS DID THIS ONE.
UH THE DETERIORATING
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE US AND
RUSSIA. IT'S HIT ROCK BOTTOM,
AND THAT'S NOT GOOD. SECONDLY
THIS IS AN ESPIONAGE CHARGE.
NOW, OBVIOUSLY, UH, EVAN WAS
DOING THIS JOB. HE'S A GOOD
JOURNALIST, BUT WITH THE
RUSSIANS AS THEY HAVE WITH PAUL
WHEELING THE ESPIONAGE CHARGES,
SOMETHING THAT IS MOST SERIOUS
TO THEM, AND THEY USE THAT
RATHER FRIVOLOUSLY. THIRD THERE
WAS AN AMERICAN, THERE WAS A
DETAINEE FROM RUSSIA THAT WAS
INDICTED IN BRAZIL BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT. SO IT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A TIP FOR CAT. BUT
THIS IS VERY DISTURBING. THIS IS
LEVELING HIGHER THE ISSUE OF
AMERICAN HOSTAGES AND HOSTAGE IS
AROUND THE WORLD. I THINK
JOURNALISTS ARE BEING THE MOST
VULNERABLE WORLDWIDE. I THINK,
JIM, WHAT IS NEEDED IS AN
INTERNATIONAL EFFORT.
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING, NOT JUST
THE U. S BUT THE EUROPEAN UNION
. AFRICAN NATIONS MIDDLE EAST
NATIONS. BECAUSE WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH IRAN, VENEZUELA,
RUSSIA MANY OTHER COUNTRIES THEY
ARE TAKING HOSTAGES, ESPECIALLY
JOURNALISTS AS BARGAINING CHIPS
, AND THAT'S REALLY UNACCEPTABLE
. UH SO, UH, I THINK THERE HAS
TO BE AN INTERNATIONAL EFFORT.
YOU KNOW, THE BRITISH THAT LOT
OF THEIR HOSTAGES ARE TAKEN, UH
, ALL AROUND THE WORLD. THIS IS
HAPPENING AND WE HAVE TO HAVE A
MULTILATERAL FRONT. AND I THINK
THE MEDIA HAS TO PLAY A ROLE ON
THE GRINDER CASE. THERE WAS A
VERY EFFECTIVE MEDIA CAMPAIGN
AND HERE IT NOT JUST THE WALL
STREET JOURNAL, A VERY RESPECTED
NEWSPAPER, BUT THE INTERNATIONAL
MEDIA COMMUNITY HAS TO RISE UP
AND RAISE THE LEVEL OF
CONSCIOUSNESS OF JOURNALISTS AND
MANY OTHERS BEING TAKEN AS
HOSTAGES AS BARGAINING CHIPS
AROUND THE WORLD. YEAH AND I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THAT
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
AND SOME OF THAT HAS ALREADY
BEGUN. BUT YOU KNOW, PAUL
WHEELAN, YOU KNOW, THE FORMER U.
S MARINE IS STILL IN A RUSSIAN
PRISON, SERVING OUT OF 16 YEAR
SENTENCE FOR THE SAME OR SORT OF
THE SAME ESPIONAGE CHARGES.
ASGER CEVICHE. UM HE WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THAT RELEASE OF
BRITTNEY GRINER. THAT WAS A ONE
FOR ONE DEAL. COULD HE BE PART
OF A TWO FOR TWO ARRANGEMENT? IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
WORKED OUT THIS TIME AROUND? WAS
THERE ANY INDICATION ON THE
RUSSIAN SIDE OF THINGS THAT THAT
WELL AND MIGHT BE A LITTLE
CLOSER, EDGING CLOSER TO BEING
PART OF SOME KIND OF A DEAL?
WELL I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
AFFECTIVELY HAD WANTED TO FOR
TOO, BUT THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN AT
THE LAST MINUTE. THE RUSSIANS
SAID ONE FOR ONE WHEELING FOR
BOOT. UM BRITTANY GRINER. FOR
NOW. MY CONCERN IS THAT THE
WHEELING AND MARINE WHO'S NOT AS
PROMINENT AS EVAN, THE
JOURNALIST, YOU KNOW IT'S KIND
OF SIDELINED. I THINK WE HAVE TO
PRESS FOR BOTH. AND THERE ARE
THREE OTHERS THERE, TOO. WE'RE
WORKING ON THEM. THREE OTHER
AMERICANS THAT I BELIEVE ARE
WRONG. AWFULLY DETAINED, SO I
THINK WE HAVE TO HAVE HIGH LEVEL
CONTACT BUT ALSO OUTSIDE PEOPLE
. THE ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
REACH OUT TO OTHER ENTITIES, UH
, THAT THAT THAT HAVE TIES IN
RUSSIA. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
BRING ESPECIALLY NOT JUST EVAN.
BUT PAUL, WE WENT HOME. HERE'S A
MARINE. HE'S BEEN THERE FOR
YEARS ON WRONGFULLY DETAINED. UH
THIS ESPIONAGE CHARGES IS NOT
REAL AS IT ISN'T FOREVER ON, BUT
IT'S GOT TO BE NEGOTIATED.
DIPLOMACY CONTACT ENGAGEMENT.
YOU CAN'T JUST, UH THROW DARTS
AT EACH OTHER. I THINK WE GOTTA
TALK AND SEPARATE HUMANITARIAN
ISSUES FROM THE GEO POLITICAL
ISSUES THAT SEPARATE THE U. S.
AND RUSSIA AND THE WHOLE UKRAINE
ISSUE. YEAH AND GOVERNOR. LET ME
ASK YOU THIS IN THIS, I THINK
DOVETAILS OFF OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE HAVING
RUSSIA. AH IS NOW HEADING THE U.
N SECURITY COUNCIL. AS YOU KNOW,
IT'S A ROTATING PRESIDENCY. BUT
I MEAN, GIVEN WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN UKRAINE RIGHT NOW, GIVEN
RUSSIA'S PATTERN OF TAKING
AMERICANS HOSTAGE. I KNOW YOU
WERE THE AMBASSADOR FOR THE U.
S. DURING THE CLINTON
MINISTRATIONS. WHAT'S YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT? I MEAN, SHOULD
SHOULD THE REST OF THE WORLD.
JUST ACCEPT THAT THAT THAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE GOING TO BE HEADING
UP THE U. N SECURITY COUNCIL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK? WELL LOOK,
YOU CAN'T DO MUCH ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THERE'S VETO POWER THAT
THE RUSSIANS HAVE. IT'S ONLY FOR
30 DAYS. UH AND THEN IT'S A
ROTATING SECURITY COUNCIL. SO
CHAIRMANSHIP SO THIS HAPPENS AND
YOU GOTTA DEAL WITH IT. YOU'VE
GOT TO BE PRAGMATIC. UH, I THINK
THIS IS WHY HIGH LEVEL BILATERAL
AND MULTILATERAL CONTACTS ARE
NEEDED TO DEAL WITH HOSTAGES.
BUT AGAIN, UH THIS CAN BE VETOED
BY THE UNITED STATES. NOT I'M
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
CHAIRMANSHIP, BUT ALL KINDS OF
ISSUES THE UNITED STATES, RUSSIA
, CHINA, BRITAIN AND FRANCE. BUT
YOU KNOW, WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT THERE. SECURITY COUNCIL
PRESIDENT FOR 30 DAYS. UH IT'S
UNFORTUNATE, BUT IT'S HAPPENING
AND IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. WE
SHOULD DEAL WITH OTHER ISSUES TO
GET OUR HOSTAGES OUT, AND THAT
SHOULD BE THE PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION. GET OUR HOSTAGES
OUT OUR VETERANS THERE OVER 70
WRONGFULLY DETAINED. THERE ARE
OTHERS LIKE GRISWALD THAT I JUST
GOT OUT. THAT ARE UNLAWFULLY
DETAINED AND ROTTING IN PRISONS
AROUND THE WORLD. YEAH WELL,
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WORK THAT
YOU DO. BEST OF LUCK. UM AND
KEEP US POSTED. IF YOU GET ANY